well it wouldn't be complete unless we
sent ted out for some holiday fun right
christian that's right he's live at the
halloween town pumpkin patch over in
boca park with some obviously a whole
bunch of folks out there with their
halloween costume and also your spooky
forecast hey ted
hey guys yeah it's so nice to be out
here
not roasting in the heat since we have
these fantastic october temperatures and
like you said this halloween town
pumpkin patch i drive by this all the
time here right along rampart there you
can see a lot of people here already of
course is going to get packed tonight
you could still come down here if you're
looking for some fun and the weather is
going to be fantastic again for this
evening you're welcome
here's your forecast right now we start
off with the current temps our weather
now nice and mild out here temperatures
are warming up winds are staying nice
and calm as you saw from our live shot
things are good for those winds they'll
increase a little later on over the
weekend here's your evening planner
look at the temperatures for tonight
looking good so if you want to come down
to the pumpkin patch looking good those
temperatures will be nice and mild for
tonight winds less than 10 all right we
want those winds light
but they will pick up again and i'm
going to pinpoint when that's going to
happen all coming up in your most active
forecast back live now again lots of
rides down here there are several
locations this isn't the only one we're
going to tell you where those other
locations are at if you can't come down
to boca park that's all coming up in
your main weather in just a few minutes
reporting live ted lorenzo live local
now back to you in studio